are you serious we are eating food that
is the same color as each other
I'm very non experimental when it comes
to food is it edible I think you should
be open-minded about trying new things
and as long as it's healthy and won't
kill you yeah I might die of food
poisoning today those color make
difference in food yes I think so I
would not eat a blue pizza this is so
[ __ ] up it looks like I have a red
pepper it's a good old ketchup it kind
of reminds me of like how sriracha might
have been made I don't put ketchup with
any food because I feel like ketchup
overpowers the taste of the foods i
don't even put ketchup on my fries I
like ketchup here we go oh that sounded
it's sensual how only cheese ketchup
this is a lot on that good job it does
taste a bit like sriracha like no joke
well God would I do it again no oven and
honey here we go oh [ __ ] am i doing
today this is another day of busking
this is something I can get on board
with cuz I love me some sweets and I
love me some nuts if there's a milk I
feel like it's gonna taste like cereal
this is really healthy for you is that
why I don't like it
also the good thing about this it's like
all-natural the more I eat it and more
I'm getting used to it I feel like
there's gonna be my favorite orange
juice and cheese also I'm lactose
intolerant this isn't the worst one so
far do you want me to like dip this
cheese in this orange juice it's not
what you want me to do you gotta bite
into it and then have some oj vine into
it and oj is that what you want me to do
yes eat it it's poison we have a Betty
taste anything cheddar cheese is very
prominent so kind of overpowers the oj
but i kind of like it there's something
really wrong with this image kids look
away yep disgusting
okay so internal voice but I can't taste
anything just leave it separate they're
good on their own don't combine them
Mediterranean mint ice cream and some
good ol wasabi are you serious Alex look
at this ice cream it's melted this is
gonna be horrendous this is a lot of
wasabi Julian
alright drink did I mention
lactose-intolerant pretty much this
whole entire video could just be like
ways to make heaven [ __ ] himself chiz
yes No Oh No aah this is not pleasant
that is probably one of the worst things
I've ever put in my mouth and put some
pretty bad things in my mouth don't try
this at home I learned that you should
leave the food as it is I mean there's a
reason why they're not together right I
like trying new things
maybe not these kinds of foods if
they're the same color they shouldn't be
mixed together that's how you make the
best of a bad situation